Teddy Walker what brings you back to
Piedmont I'm glad you asked right now I
have an amazing job of sales but I'm
here now to get my GB you would have to
go to night school you're in my house
are you doing the black voice no I don't
hear color you're the night school
teacher no I'm just the [ __ ] that like
to wear blouses yes I'm the night school
teacher let's do some introductions hey
yo what up I'm Bobby
you can skype into the class yeah if
you're doing time at the Georgia
Correctional Facility your next name's
Jalen how about you ma'am I dropped out
of high school so I wanted to get my GED
before it has to live in Randy's parents
laundry room my name is Luis I'm going
to become a singer-songwriter oh no not
like Julio Iglesias oh it's gonna be a
long semester that's what's up
he's not like the teachers that we had
back in the day this woman is a brick
wall
school policy if you don't pass that
test you're out once those tests really
why don't you wear black on laundry day
so you wore yellow it's fresh it's clean
you don't my face what's it look like
I'm doing you gonna take my car my baby
in the backseat Oh baby in there Wayne
Wayne petty suit you got a lot it's
dumbest hey I'm where I'm supposed to be
at a fast-food joint next to a strip
club
why stand in the right spot I can smell
cocoa butter and fried chicken at the
same time I need you to go out there and
I need you to stop no no I can't flirt
and my day was innocent now it's all
about the bots heard a guy they I'm
gonna correct that but like a walnut
did you start there wouldn't you want to
start in the front to stop it this dance
is for students only get out my way
[ __ ]
thank you buddy what's up please please
continue with the Pythagorean theory
the issue is you're clinically dumb I
knew it there's no cure for what you
have oh my god I got learning herpes
there's no such thing as learning herpes
ah you must Muslim wait I'm sorry what
what's going okay why we gonna wing
what's the square root of 81 what what's
the square root of 81 I don't know
you